and finally new rule democrats must
thank president biden for his great
service to america and then move him
into a more ceremonial role
let me finish
joe biden has been president now for a
year and a day the day was pretty good
but the year
not horrible certainly better than the
alternative but for some reason america
has lost its faith in joe sometimes that
just happens a new cbs poll has just
over a quarter of americans saying the
country is going in the right direction
and the quinnipiac poll has biden's year
one approval rating at 33 percent the
lowest for any president ever even trump
33 percent if he were a movie he'd be
listed as certified rotten
now of course he's not and what's gone
wrong is certainly not all joe's fault
but the hard fact is even when joe does
something good he seems to get no credit
our economy is actually pretty awesome
considering what we've just been through
wages are up workers have more leverage
we avoided a recession
stocks just had their best year since
1995 and yet only 38 percent approve of
his handling of the economy
this is what happens when you lack
passionate defenders
as opposed to trump who every day [ __ ]
the bed and 90 of republicans blame the
bed
and
biden may well have even further to fall
because there's no die-hard biden base
his is a coalition of the unenthused
no one ever fainted during one of his
speeches or claimed biden was appointed
by god or asked him to sign their tits
when he first got into office i told you
that biden was like non-dairy creamer
nobody's first choice but he got the job
done
and
he did get the job done in 2020 when his
nation needed him to beat trump and he
did but
[Applause]
but
fair or not to most people now it looks
like joe biden's get up and go got up
and went
there's no big dick energy coming out of
the democratic party
[Applause]
and their bench is so thin they were
even talking about running hillary again
and uh and i'm sure she's thinking well
who else do you got
kamala her approval rating is lower than
biden's
bernie's too old and pete's too young
and
this didn't work out
but
[Music]
but there is one guy
all democrats could rally behind and
would love to see back in the white
house
now
now of course you're saying but obama
can't be president again he's had two
terms and that's the rule
yeah the rule
you know politics often called the art
of the possible really has now become
the art of whatever you can get away
with something only republicans seem to
realize
like when they just made up that
presidents can't appoint a supreme court
justice in an election year
or when they changed their mind and said
oh wait they can when our side is in
power
here's mitch mcconnell telling us in
2016 that he's not
not even going to give obama supreme
court pick a hearing because there's
only eight months to the election
american people need to weigh in and
decide
who's going to make this decision not
this lame duck president on the way out
the door
but the next president next year
and here he is on whether they'd fill a
seat if there was an opening during
trump's last year in office
and then they did eight days before an
election to them hypocrisy is not a bug
it's a feature
they're all about grinning in the mirror
as they shove it up your ass like jesus
would do
that is the essence of trumpism you want
to see my tax returns show me where
that's written down you want me to
concede when i lose that's just a
tradition
now here at real time as a way to
describe this phenomenon
we like to remember gus that's the 70s
disney movie about a mule named gus who
gets signed by a football team to kick
field goals with his powerful leg
because there was nothing specifically
in the rulebook
that said a team couldn't sign and play
a mule
trump
trump pulled a gus every day when he was
in the white house
not
divesting his businesses making his
son-in-law our de facto prime minister
filling cabinet departments with acting
secretaries so they wouldn't have to
undergo being approved by the senate
screwing with the post office to make it
harder to vote
all presidents pardoned some shady
people but he was the first to say [ __ ]
it i'll give it to myself
what the democrats have to do now is
their version of a gus
and it goes like this
biden and obama must divorce their wives
not leave them
just officially legally
divorce them then biden will gay marry
obama
[Applause]
thereby putting him back in the white
house
yes the law the law says obama can't be
president again but there's nothing that
says he can't be first lady
[Applause]
and if obama was back as biden's husband
the democratic party would get its mojo
back and we'd have confidence that the
person really running the show was the
person we really want running the show
and biden of course would still have
value
like that extra pope they keep in rome
[Applause]
when obama did something good joe could
stand behind him and say this is a big
[ __ ] deal
historians say that when woodrow wilson
had a stroke his wife edith secretly ran
the country for a year and a half can
democrats do it again say it with me yes
we can
except
except this time do it proudly with that
smug mitch mcconnell look on your face
like yeah we know it's wrong and never
been done but that's all secondary to
[ __ ] you and loving it
don't whine that oh but biden and obama
aren't really gay yes that's the whole
point
although
although if the two of them ever did
have a slow dance while beyonce
serenaded them without last
i'm sure msnbc would explode into
rainbow skittles
but
but that's that's that's not where we're
going with this this isn't not this is
not about gay this is about showing that
democrats can play by gus rules too
trump lost the popular vote in both of
his elections and still got to put three
judges on the supreme court so don't ask
me to feel bad about first lady barack
obama
i mean
what's the big deal mitch in america the
first lady always gets a pet project she
feels passionate about laura bush had
literacy and
michelle obama had fitness and melania
had anti-bullying
really
obama will be no different it's just
that his first lady project
is running the federal government
you